Міністерство оборони Азербайджану в середу, 20 вересня,
опублікувало відео, на якому стверджується,
що вірменські сили тікають з окопів у Нагірному Карабасі.
На цих відео, знятих з повітря, можна побачити людей, які йдуть через траншеї.
Раніше в середу міністерство повідомило, що вірменські сили в Карабаху
погодилися "скласти зброю, залишити бойові позиції та військові пости
та повністю роззброїтися", а вся зброя та важка техніка
буде передана азербайджанській армії, цитує Reuters.
Напередодні у Нагірному Карабасі заявили про припинення вогню з 13 години за місцевим часом.
Влада невизнаної республіки повідомила, що складає зброю і виводить свої війська з регіону.
Міноборони Азербайджану підтверджує досягнення домовленостей про припинення вогню.
Усе це сталося через добу після того, як азербайджанська армія почала наступ у Нагірному Карабасі.
Напередодні, 19 вересня, Азербайджан почав у Карабасі так звані "антитерористичні заходи",
які, за його словами, були розпочаті після того,
як "двоє військових і четверо мирних жителів загинули в результаті підриву на мінах".
Вимогами Азербайджану було роззброєння та виведення вірменських військ
і розпуск уряду невизнаної "Нагірно-Карабаської Республіки".
Це не стало несподіванкою, оскільки ми бачили,
як протягом останніх тижнів, якщо не місяців, триває нарощування військ.
Тож ми боялися або очікували, що щось подібне може статися будь-якої миті.
Проте я особливо здивований, що це відбувається під час засідання ООН,
поки всі зосереджені на Україні, поки весь світ збирається в Нью-Йорку.
Мати це тут, на Кавказі, дивний знак, що це відбувається саме зараз.
Це одне. І інше, я думаю, що між Азербайджаном, Росією та Туреччиною, ймовірно,
була домовленість, щоб запустити певну операцію прямо зараз.
Азербайджанська армія оголосила про проведення військової операції
в Карабаху з метою "відновлення конституційного ладу".
Єреван присутність своїх військових у Карабаху заперечує.
Внаслідок обстрілів загинули 32 особи, у тому числі 7 мирних жителів,
поранено понад 200 людей, заявила омбудсмен Вірменії Анаїт Манасян.
У Вірменії тривали масові протести. Протестувальники вимагали від керівництва країни вжити заходів для припинення війни.
Та деякі експерти наголошували, що вірменські війська в регіоні не мають сил протистояти Азербайджану.
Тепер вибір стоїть дуже простий. Чи перекинеться ця війна до Вірменії чи ні?
Вона перекинеться, якщо вірменські збройні сили зараз вступлять у бій,
якщо вони будуть у відповідь зі своєї території якось обстрілювати азербайджанські позиції,
які, відповідно, обстрілюють Степанакерт.
Але в такому разі Вірменія сама зазнає втягування в цю війну.
В іншому випадку, якщо Вірменія не втручатиметься, то, мабуть, бойові дії
можуть завершитися дуже швидко, тому що ті сили, які є в Карабаху,
вірменські сили не мають особливого потенціалу до опору Азербайджану.
У ЄС засудили ескалацію та закликали Азербайджан повернутися до діалогу.
Про це йдеться у заяві глави зовнішньополітичного відомства Жозепа Борреля.
Експерти звертали увагу на повідомлення про концентрацію азербайджанських військових
поблизу Нагірного Карабаху в останні кілька тижнів,
а також про постачання зброї з Ізраїлю до Азербайджану.
Я думаю, що це було за згодою Москви та Анкари.
Я припускав, що цю "відмашку" мали дати минулого тижня, але це сталося зараз.
І я не думаю, що в Азербайджані вірили у те, у що хотілося б
– а саме у безумовну передачу влади.
Ішлося про те, щоб за допомогою покрокової тактики забрати регіон під свій вплив.
Це тривало багато місяців. І тепер пішло в хід вичавлювання людей.
Це результат системних підготовок до цього.
І справа дійшла до якоїсь точки, де було отримано добро на прохід до наступної.
На допомогу у врегулюванні конфлікту, що спалахнув, закликав прем'єр Вірменії Нікол Пашинян.
При чому чекав він на неї, судячи з його заяви,
зокрема від російської сторони, чиї миротворці розміщені в Нагірному Карабаху.
Фактично Азербайджан розпочав наземну операцію, спрямовану на етнічне чищення вірмен Нагірного Карабаху.
Як йдеться у заяві МЗС Вірменії, по-перше, російські миротворчі сили мають вжити заходів.
По-друге, ми очікуємо, що Рада Безпеки ООН також вживатиме відповідних заходів.
Багато експертів неодноразово звертали увагу на похолодання у відносинах Москви та Єревану.
І навіть вбачали у діях Вірменії розворот від Росії, а в діях Росії
– бажання помститися союзнику за зраду.
Кремль наполягає, що зберігає з Вірменією партнерські відносини.
Президент Туреччини Реджеп Таїп Ердоган у своїй промові перед Генасамблеєю ООН
також послався на суверенітет Азербайджану і буквально висловив свою підтримку діям Баку
в день проведення так званих "антитерористичних заходів" у Нагірному Карабаху,
які призвели до загибелі понад 30 осіб.
Як зараз усі визнають, Карабах є територією Азербайджану,
тому жодного іншого статусу не може бути диктовано.
Наша головна мета повинна полягати в тому, щоб усі, включаючи вірмен,
жили мирно пліч-о-пліч на азербайджанських землях.
Ми підтримуємо кроки, які роблять Азербайджан, і дії під гаслом однієї держави,
двох народів, для захисту своєї територіальної цілісності.
А у міноборони Азербайджану заявляли, що дії Баку
були відповіддю на провокацію з боку Вірменії.
Ми спостерігали такі кроки, як приведення підрозділів у високий рівень бойової готовності,
створення додаткових підрозділів для мобілізації,
посилення розвідки у бік азербайджанської армії,
проникнення в глибину наших позицій та повторне мінування розмінованих територій,
а також цивільних шляхів з метою терористичної провокації.
Однак, Штефан Майстер, порівнюючи ризики та можливості сторін,
скептично ставиться до подібних заяв.
Потрібен був привід для нападу. Ну я маю на увазі, що ні вірмени Нагірного Карабаху,
ні Єреван не в змозі протистояти Баку у військовому відношенні,
тому було б безглуздо, так би мовити, їх провокувати,
і це теж типовий засіб Росії та пострадянського простору
– звинувачувати опонента в тому, що робите ви самі, провокуєте, щоб виправдати напад.
Роззброєння вірменських формувань у Карабасі та виведення військових,
за словами Азербайджану, відбувається в координації з російськими миротворцями.
Однак говорити про повну деескалацію конфлікту поки що зарано.